today's episode is brought to you by the
u.s army
[Music]
they welcomed you to jurassic park then
they welcomed
you to the lost world now the franchise
just kinda wears out its welcome in
jurassic park three alan
before you see the fifth jurassic movie
revisit the chapter
that made these movies go extinct for 15
years
combining a rehashed plot you mean their
two islands and dinosaurs
and tv quality effects
[Music]
to score the lowest critical response of
the series uh
why couldn't universal have just
listened to jeff goldblum they were so
preoccupied with whether or not they
could they didn't stop to think if they
should
alan sam neil returns as indiana jones
minus all charisma it's a great thing
about bones they never run away
witness the most meta role of his career
as he plays a guy pressured by fans into
going back to jurassic park
does anyone have a question that does
not relate to jurassic park
who finally gives in because of a
paycheck i could write all kinds of
numbers on this check dr grant
while his more successful co-star
literally phones in her part from home
hello they'll be joined by a cast of new
dumb characters
like billy who carries a parachute on
land
for the entire movie just in case this
happens
the mandatory jurassic park child of
divorce taylor yelling
and william h macy as a timid paint
salesman who scams a team of mercenaries
and kidnaps dr grant to rescue his kid
from the hot shot who's dating his wife
huh i think if they told the story from
his perspective this movie might
actually be good
this is t-rex p
never mind alan do you like dinosaurs
well not for long because this movie
ruins every last one of them
killing off the t-rex in seconds just to
show how badass the spinosaurus is
weirdly obsessing over the raptor's
vocal cords do you remember the sounds
they made
and making the dinosaurs earth-shakingly
loud
but still has them sneak up on people
like teflon-clad ninjas
[Music]
alan so gear up for the most forgettable
jurassic park movie
that forgot to include any antagonists
forgot to save any of its budget for an
actual ending
she said the navy and the marines and
forgot they put the phrase my god into
the script nine different times
thank god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
he's dead oh my god no he's not
oh my god
it's a bird cage my god that's lazy
alan starring
alan shameless taya and the t-rex
this pratt let me put you on holdover a
minute
people tripping all over themselves
[Music]
and this velociraptor on a plane
shouting alan
alan the one where a dinosaur says alan
i'm just going to go ahead and pretend
this whole movie is a dream prequel to
the lego video game
[Music]
dr grant today's episode was brought to
you by the us army
find out more by clicking the link below
allen
and when everybody has an awesome voice
no one will
i didn't choose the honest trailer life
the honest trailer life chose me
chicago